visto en esta tarde sé incluso si el
primer ministro, ahora encuentra el segundo
tiempo que vivimos con nueces y peras
Muchas críticas chocan con los sondrios
la explosión te veo ya en la primera
Vuelta le preguntó qué peso se pone
verano en este en que es el tiempo
de la campaña
con el buen juan ie ah una cita
principal preocupación si lo usa
una lista de cuentas Brasil Eh hijo Las
en esto está la precisión de la tormenta
en la segunda guerra entre mantenerlo en
cuenta que Bonucci que es sera sol en
esto sobreestima mi única señal
porcentaje de los swatus que les sisea
puede sonar la primera vez que se quede eso
entró esta noche el segundo
la calidad de la experiencia se mantuvo precisa
que la deprime porque tiene un poco
el hidro calibrar en el modelo base y es
uno de los resultados electorales que luego
primera vez y esto es importante para mantener
en cuenta qué ansiedad y después de seis años o qué
No me aferré a una sensación de pulpación
brasileira a Las máscaras en esta área es
ya considerado
pero ahora es un voto ya es un deber decidir y
probablemente con un maestro típico
macho lo tiene junto
de momento no son 4 y 6.700 personas
[Música]
ahora tengo un poco de economía y eso es todo
campaña parece terminar Quién es
incluso preguntarme no mueve la
Señor sea antes de que vieras que allí
voy a mostrar mingo
lo que le quites no va a cambiar
mucho láser en este como Lula eh
muchos primera parte
Ah y en la ultima parte emotiva o la
retos un poco como leo el que nada
si doy un poco ya que un error es en total
siempre y cuando er la persona sbrain Mars la
antes de que fuera un juego es inteligente importante
Yo creo que no va a cambiar trapeadores Eh la
situación en la que entramos
situación